but after with emotional problems i find
this hard to believe what the [ __ ] keep
going I am acting here and this [ __ ]
wanders onto my set I don't even get a
line out until don't be the dick starts
whispering in your ear you're not even
watching anymore Dennis Dennis don't
[ __ ] Dennis me I am doing my job here
I am a pro this is the most
unprofessional cent I have ever been on
this is horseshit I've got these [ __ ]
zombies over here that I have to look at
I have a bunch of [ __ ] staring at me
and this [ __ ] baby [ __ ] is garbage
whoa be all right so the baby the
zombies that is by far Dennis Quaid's
best acting performance ever now there's
a rumor i should say right up top there
is a rumor that maybe it was staged we
have no reason to believe that though
but somebody was saying that maybe jimmy
kimmel made this thing happen anyway if
it wasn't staged that's his best working
oscar-worthy Oscar ready what I'm
curious about is who qualifies as baby
who qualifies as [ __ ] and we call about
the zombie like I want to know who falls
into which category yeah cuz there only
seems to be one baby some like there's
only one baby but there are multiple
[ __ ] and multiple zombies I'm like I
won't know what don't be an addictive oh
so you don't think way too baby so yeah
I thought there was actually a baby like
that baby baby but the baby didn't make
any noise if anybody he was the biggest
baby there so yea what did he think was
a baby that's a big I just wanted to
know yeah that's an important question
what do you think of when they leaked
these things like we've seen this before
with plenty of actors having these
mental breakdowns do you think it's like
specific to actors or they could catch
any of us one day having these like
crazy meltdown and that's the thing i
feel kind of bad for him if it is real i
feel bad just because like everyone has
that moment where they break down and
that's the worst version of you in the
worst possible situation when you're
really frustrated and I wouldn't want
that to be like
shirt and put on the internet and
representative of me yeah I hear you
there is something those special about
actors like the way he was yelling like
it's all about me this is what I'm doing
you're staring like he's angry that
people are staring at him but what are
they supposed to do on a set I hear you
and I take your point I think you're
right but to something it is the worst
time to catch them but at the same time
it's like what we do and i classify
myself as an actor because that's how I
make my money you're welcome um but
we've got mics on so like where we're at
we were performing yeah and for me it's
still where you have to there's some
amount of humility that you have to have
with everything yeah with everything
that you do and I think that it gets it
can get to a point sometimes where you
forget that you're not curing cancer you
ain't you ain't solving world hunger
right now or the energy crisis or you
know fixing global warming you just
Ekans so calm your tits so is that
because I apologies but the tits was not
calm yo tits I say that every day I know
um so is that it like actors there's
like this self-importance with them
right like they have to get into
character so I can understand that at
some level but they're not actually
nuclear scientists they're not actually
curing cancer people always like they're
such geniuses but I'm not doing the real
thing they're just pretending I think
about like road rage for a second people
get so angry when they're driving when
someone cuts them off its gonna delay
them like a second to get to where
they're going but it's just you know
sometimes you're just in that really
pissed off moment and someone gets to
you and actors especially like it takes
a lot to get into character sometimes
and to put yourself into that role so
whenever somebody breaks your
concentration over and over again I can
see how that would be very for like I of
course he should be humble and shouldn't
act like a child and stomp his feet I'm
he's been good of an actress only it
made me crazy I just had a bad for him
that that is his like image now yeah
have you guys ever been caught on camera
doing something that you shouldn't been
doing or not real I like had a hot mic
or anything like that yeah it's all
youtube.com slash hey yo Shanna you're
welcome it's every day yeah no not
really
nothing i mean i don't think that bad
about me my youtube channel never camera
in your house everything i say is on
purpose yeah i did happen to me one time
at my old studio they they left the mic
on i didn't realize that a zillion
people were suddenly tweeting at me
asking me why I was talking about high
school and this guy that I hated I'd
like to publicly apologize to keep from
Syosset you're not that terrible